you must say that noise you cannot
allow yourself to say that I'm too old
ever again I don't care if you're 98 you
know that you have 15 seconds left to
live don't buy into the myth that you're
too old because that is going to slow
you down there is a quote that haunts me
to my core which is genius is a young
man's game why is genius a young man's
game part of it is definitely energy
part of it is the naivete of the
beginner but part of it is just that as
you get older you become dogmatic you
start saying like I'm too old you start
buying into the myth that you can't
teach an old dog new tricks the reality
is your brain remains plastic until the
day you die meaning you can learn new
things the human animal is designed to
learn that's what we are designed to do
when you're younger it's easier you
learn at a more accelerated rate I'm not
denying that but if you lose sight of
the fact you really can learn it at any
age and by the way as you get older you
have wisdom you have better tools for
learning so there's an efficiency to
learning that is not present when you're
young in terms of tools and tactics that
you definitely have when you're older
and so you also have more will more
drive more reason and so if you can
manage your energy on both a
psychological level because your
psychology is going to have a huge
influence over the neurochemistry that
you pump if you've ever put on a good
song and that energy fills you up that
song Got You hyped you secreted dopamine
and now you felt more alive need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I quit on my business partner I
was making 300 bucks a month and I
didn't have the motivation to keep going
and the thing that got me through was
studying the stories of entrepreneurs
who've had massive success and I hope
that in sharing these stories with you
you find a motivation to keep going and
if I'm being honest I still need the
source for myself today too so today
let's learn from one of the best Tom
bilyu and my take on his top 10 was a
success enjoy
[Music]
the problem is as you get older you try
things you find the things that work and
the world of things that the young
people are trying which is why they
don't know what the is going to
work so they're trying everything begins
to narrow narrow narrow narrow narrow
narrow narrow until you're like ah here
is that narrow bandwidth that actually
works when you get there and you think
you're at the Pinnacle you are my friend
that is how people get trapped by being
old
you've got to discard all that
and say I'm gonna try things maybe it
didn't work in the past but maybe it'll
work now read voraciously find new ideas
put them to use if you learn something
use it that day push yourself push
yourself to get better to get faster to
learn new things reading podcasts
YouTube videos I am insatiable in my
appetite for knowledge because I am
always shocked one the world is learning
new things and two I'm discovering new
things that interact with my wiring
right we're all we all have about 50
hard wiring so we are not blank slates
so it's interacting with the unique way
that I think about things but it's also
interacting with the things that I've
learned the current climate of what's
happening and all that but if you're not
taking in new ideas then you can't get
new ideas out
so I used to have this formula that hung
over my desk and it said ideas in equal
ideas out you've got to voraciously get
those ideas in so that noise about
being too old that is a self-defeating
way to think about it never ever repeat
disempowering
like I'm too old ever again and then go
out there learn to code become the
greatest coder that ever lived you're 98
you got a long ass beard and you go
better than anybody else and God only
knows what the language will be then but
you're gonna beat these young
whippersnappers and if you maintain that
idea my friend you will stay mentally
Supple and you will dominate dominate I
say so get after it you can learn
anybody can rule number two stay focused
one of the coolest quotes I've ever
heard in my life is don't sell out what
you want most for what you want right
now and I think that is a quote to live
by right there so that's the big one is
really making sure that you are focused
and excited about what it is that you
want long term and even just having a
phrase that you can say to yourself
about what it is that you want most I
think would be hugely beneficial so
often people don't have that level of
clarity so when we're talking about
procrastination just the raw desire to
actually see something through to the
end um is going to be critically
important now the rest of what we're
talking about is very mechanistic but I
want to go through it so first of all
anything that's disrupting the rhythm of
your day is going to be wildly
problematic I will answer the question
assuming that there's just absolutely
nothing you can do about that but I want
to sneak in a quick little answer for
anybody else that finds themselves in a
similar situation if there's any way for
you to get out of the situation where
you are constantly having the rhythm of
your day disrupted I highly encourage it
so we're about to go through how you can
regiment the chaos but first and
foremost would be to not find yourself
in the chaos to begin with and that
really does matter in terms of when I
think about my own life and trying to be
as deadly efficient with every single
moment that I have
eliminating disruptions is a big one
okay now assuming that you can't
eliminate the disruptions then you're
going to need to start building some
rules into your life so that any moment
where you have let's say that rule might
be if I have any consecutive three
minutes where I know three minutes are
available then I'm going to immediately
do X now that X might be journaling so
you keep um something like Evernote on
your phone and you have a topic
pre-ordained something you already know
that you're going to do and whenever you
have a gap because look some gaps just
aren't going to be worth it so if I had
a 90 second Gap I may not fuss with it
it's going to take 20 seconds just to
get your phone out and get the app open
and have it refresh and all of that but
if you're really hardcore and you say
anytime where I have a three minute
stretch then I'm going to make sure that
I immediately begin doing something
that's productive a big part of making
limited Windows like that productive is
the following so first and foremost is
having an important things list and by
having that important things let's
you're going to be able to immediately
slide into knowing exactly what you
should be doing so that you don't spend
the three minutes just trying to figure
out what it is that you're going to do
so you're going to have that important
things list you're going to know exactly
what you should be doing you're going to
build in some minimum amount of time
where you say anytime where I have this
amount of time or more I'm immediately
going to dive into one of the things of
my important things list now important
things this shouldn't all be just these
gargantuan things that require hours and
hours of time you want to make sure that
you have things that you can do that are
long you want to make sure that you have
some things that are medium and you want
to make sure that you have some things
that are short and when you have that
now you can begin sliding into those
some of what you may be doing in the
short maybe researching something
learning more about so you're talking a
lot about film and TV so I can just tell
you right now that I have a YouTube
playlist which I also curate ahead of
time so anytime I've got a brief window
it's what I call transitional moments
where I immediately pick up my phone
take it out go into let's say
screenwriting boom I've already got 20
20 videos that are just going to auto
play so I have to select the next one
curated on that playlist boom I started
going and now I'm researching another
thing that I can do in very limited
Windows of time
is I have specific stories that I'm
going to be journaling on and I might
journal for a minute I might journal for
an hour depending on how much time I
have but every second that I spend
working on that I'm able to eat a little
bit more productivity out of it so
that's huge you're going to need to make
sure that you get sleep that's going to
be really critical and then you need to
prioritize things in your life you
mentioned your wife so for me my wife is
number one now not in terms of time
allocation but in terms of importance so
when I know that there's any friction
there I'm going to deal with that first
when there's um you know I need to
capture Joy or something to really
reaffirm the relationship and make sure
that it is this Beacon of joy and hope
in my life I'm going to do that so
putting your your
um values in life in ranked order is
going to be critically important to you
rule number three keep your motivation
up motivation comes in waves that's the
most important thing to understand is
and that's just neurobiology so that's
true for everybody motivation is it is a
very complicated cocktail of beliefs of
excitement thinking about you know what
you're going to achieve it is how your
calorie count is how much sleep you've
gotten all of these things bundled up
and so it is inevitable that sometimes
you're really going to feel it and
sometimes you're not I am blown away
that you were able to get a seven day
streak most people go their entire lives
and not be able to string something like
that together so some of what we're
going to be doing to get you back in
that space is to remember what it was
that had you stoked in the beginning so
a big part of motivation is is always
about actually wanting that thing at the
end of the rainbow so what is your pot
of gold what is the thing that made you
want to do this in the first place and
so when it comes to working out
personally I absolutely hate working out
so I understand anybody that has
motivation for a minute and then ends up
burning out I get that so much I can't
even begin to tell you so here are the
things that I do to make sure that even
as these sort of Ebbs and flows go of my
mode motivation that I stay on track
number one is making sure that you want
that thing at the end that you're
actually excited about that so you've
got to be honest with yourself about
what it is that you want so often people
are judging themselves for what it is
that they want that they don't double
down on focusing on that thing so let's
say that you just want to look good when
you're naked and that that is the the
God's honest truth about what is getting
you excited about this and what you're
going to want to say is you know this is
about longevity I just want to be
healthy I want to be you know my best
self but in reality you're just thinking
about six-pack abs washboard stomach or
the way you look when you catch yourself
in the mirror what whatever is real or
if you're like me and you're a
psychopath about wanting to live forever
and that really is the thing that
motivates you then lean into that but
don't let other people's judgments about
what you should want color what you
actually want
so that's the the beginning focus on
what what is it you really want what is
it you really care about grab onto that
focus on that start fantasizing about
that again spending time thinking about
what it would be like to actually have
that because you set a word in your
question that I want to take exception
to which is that you want to find your
motivation again you don't find
motivation you build motivation so we're
going to build that motivation back up
by admitting what we really want by
focusing on it and getting hype about it
and then we also want to find a way to
really fall in love with the process so
what is it in the moment in the act of
actually working out that you can get
into is it the um getting stronger for
me that was huge like knowing that I was
getting stronger and I needed to
associate something with that you want
to have a self-narrative around showing
up and doing this thing when you know
other people can't they won't during
covet during lockdown they're getting
worse they're getting weaker you're
getting stronger you're getting better
and people are so weird
about competition
but my friend let me tell you what one
of the most controversial posts that I
posted recently which I did not expect
to be controversial was that I was
talking about business
but I said this is a competition
which is patently self-evident in my
opinion
but being willing to compete with others
and to have a self-narrative around
striving and pushing and doing more than
other people are willing to do that will
feed your soul in a way that I can't
convey and people that are afraid to
compete people that are afraid to lean
in people are that are afraid to make
huge demands of themselves they will
fall by the wayside to the people that
can have that discipline that get
excited about pushing themselves being
accountable being consistent because
ultimately those things lead to an
actual outcome meaning you actually do
get stronger you do get better you look
better you have better longevity better
stamina whatever it is whatever that
thing is that you're motivated by you
really can achieve that but you have to
be consistent now I got motivated just
answering your question so I'm very
hopeful that that motivated you as well
rule number four commit fully the big
thing and this is why I always tell
people there need to be two things true
about the goals you're trying to
accomplish one they need to be honorable
and two they need to be exciting so
we'll set honorable aside for a second
and just focus on being just absolutely
committed out of enthusiasm to
accomplishing your goal and this has
been one of the things that's propelled
me the most in my career is that I
legitimately am excited about the thing
that I'm trying to build and because I
value myself for this sincere pursuit of
this thing that is both exciting to me
and honorable in that it's you know
going to lift people up if I actually
accomplish it and I'm holding myself
accountable to actual results but the
game the game which is the right way to
think about it the game of trying to
turn my potential into usable skills
that can do something tangible in the
world to make that goal that's exciting
and honorable come true because all of
that game is predicated on making sure
that I love the time in the field that
I'm leaving everything out on the field
and I value myself for that I don't
value myself for accomplishing it but I
value myself for actually trying to
pursue it so now you can imagine and I'm
saying this stuff to myself all the time
so the weekends are fun and I do wife
oriented things and I'm doing like in
your case I would be doing the things
that are oriented around my kids and I
would love it and I would have work shut
off in my mind and I wouldn't be trying
to work double duty on the weekends I
will be with my kids and then on during
the week I'm gonna be focused on that
goal that I want to be focused on now
here is the catch
if your value system is such that family
time is far more important and exciting
to you than work time you may want to
reevaluate your goals because it may be
that you're trying to convince yourself
to pursue something Monday through
Friday that actually doesn't resonate
with you now if that's true you've got a
couple different options you can either
find a way to make the stuff that you
want to do with your family for your
family that skill set you can find a way
to make that a big part of your Monday
through Friday so that it feels like
more of a continuation of the week it
may not be play time and I get it
everybody has to eat and pay your bills
and so you're gonna have to find
something to monetize but there are
often things what I call Universe of so
if family time quality time with your
kids that's a skill set that you want to
be extraordinary at what's a way where
you could be in the universe of that
skill set those things during the week
so that you saw a direct correlation
between what you do during the week and
then that thing that really matters to
you which is your family time on the
weekend so it could be pursuing a degree
in Psychology it could be working at a
daycare it could be teaching you know I
don't know in what way that to you is
sort of the deep passion but that's
another way to approach this there's no
right or wrong goal there is only a goal
that is both exciting and honorable and
gets you amped on Monday so that the way
you're pursuing it through the week is
exciting to to and you don't feel like
you're living for the weekend and that's
where people are often falling apart is
their Monday through Friday is a should
thing it's I should want this I should
pursue this instead of being a
continuation of just the things in life
that they love and the way that I've
tried to structure my life is such that
on the weekend other than spending time
with my wife the most exciting thing
that I can think of to do are the fun
parts of my Monday through Friday that's
how much I enjoy what I'm pursuing and
what I'm trying to build is that sure
there's overhead look I I will say that
my work life is comprised of 60 overhead
meaning things I don't want to do and 40
things I do want to do but those that 40
is so much fun and the sixty percent
serves that 40 so well that on the
weekend I can pull from that 40 and and
just be energized and feel wildly
enthusiastic that it's the best way that
I could spend my totally free time and
that is a sign that you've got things
aligned so that would be my
encouragement if you find yourself
having a hard time revving back up it
tells me that you figured something out
on the weekends that you haven't yet
figured out during the week
find a way to align them also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five push yourself
being an artist right now this is like
the best possible time to have something
that you can do by yourself that you can
improve on by yourself that's ultimately
going to have real world consequences
for you when we get to the other side of
this so here is is and and something
tells me that if you're playing
professionally you already know this but
here is the the reality about greatness
greatness is about doing the things that
are tragically boring and that you have
to repeat over and over and over to get
better at them in a deliberate way you
don't just want to repeat them blindly
but in a deliberate way buckling down
and doing the things like for a musician
playing your scales practicing your
improvisation practicing your cold
reading all of the things that are very
easy to put off when you have a job and
you're busy and you're making a living
it's it's kind of like typing what they
find is most people sort of their their
typing rated if I remember rights like
65 to 70 words per minute is where most
people tap out but I think the record is
somewhere around 250 correct words per
minute so if the average person is
tapping out around 65 but the Delta is
all the way between 65 and 250 you begin
to see like how far you you can really
push yourself but people get to a level
that they deem acceptable and they just
sort of stop there but because everybody
is being forced to shut down right now
if you're a musician and you're saying
look I'm not worried about streaming and
going live and all of that which I think
there's a whole question to be answered
about doing that and about how you could
generate even more Revenue by going
online but you asked me to set that
aside so I'm going to set that aside but
right now is that chance to embrace a
level of boredom that most people are
not willing to push through in order to
get to Greatness so in a business
context I always tell people boredom
kills more entrepreneurs than anything
it kills more entrepreneurs than fear
most people they just can't slog through
sucking at something and sitting in the
discomfort that you get from doing the
things that you're not good at long
enough to get good at even those things
so that you can truly go out and create
art because I don't think you can create
real art until you've mastered the
basics to the point where as Bruce Lee
said you don't think kick you just kick
and I love that quote there's another
Bruce Lee idea which is I Don't Fear the
man who knows 10 000 kicks I fear or I
don't fear the man that does 10 000
kicks one time I fear the man that does
one kick ten thousand times and that is
this moment and if you can take this
down time and let go of how good it
feels to perform I have to imagine a big
part of the reason you got into this and
that you did all of the work when you
were younger to get good is because you
love performing so much but right now
that's basically off the table
so if in this moment you can buckle down
be disciplined set your sights on
something very specific that you want to
get good at disciplined practice at that
thing to get good at this on the other
side of this you're going to be far more
extraordinary than you were when you
went in because you no longer have the
distractions of the actual performance
you can just get down to practicing so
flip that switch in your mind and think
all about coming out the other side of
this a beast an absolute monster better
than you went in and if you can tell
yourself that story I'm committed to
this I'm willing to do these things that
other people aren't willing to do and
put in the practice and understand as
you're going through that unimaginable
boredom that on the other side of this
is a skill set that has utility
then this becomes an extraordinary time
but if you keep telling yourself the
story that so many others are telling
which is this is you know a time of
deprivation it's um just lamenting that
you're not able to perform and all the
things that made you love music in the
first place then just because you're
repeating that it becomes a dark time
focus on the other side and you will get
through this amazingly well number six
set your goals there is a metric ton of
uncertainty right now there's no two
ways about that but you get to control
how you spend your time so when you
think about making the most of this time
if you allow yourself to get overwhelmed
by the uncertainty then
you're going to be paralyzed and you're
not going to make good use of this time
versus if you know what you want to be
accomplishing you know exactly what your
goal is you know hey six months from now
I want to be doing this a year from now
I want to be doing this whatever you
can't control what happens to the world
so literally shut that out of your mind
build the skill set that you want to
build that allows you to do the things
you want to do
at the end of six months a year 18
months two years whatever that is
however far out that you're looking
skills have utility decide what that
skill set is and now we're going to
spend the time building that because
that is something that we can control we
can go in and we can get good at that
thing now when you're on in the process
of getting good hitting plateaus is
absolutely unavoidable what you want to
do is figure out what is it that's
beginning to break down so if you're a
violinist what is it do you have a hard
time reading music cold reading do you
have a hard time with the finger
positioning do you have a hard time with
changing tempos like whatever is the
weakness that makes you feel like you've
plateaued you have to identify what the
difference is between where you are and
where you want to be now oftentimes as
identifying somebody who's better than
you and saying why are they better than
me and not like in a judgment about
their Worth or anything like that just
what is it that they do better than me
and then begin to dissect it look there
is quite literally much to my dismay
nothing that as of today I'm the best in
the world at now uh drives me crazy when
people do this sure I could sub segment
things far down enough to say that you
know I'm the best person recording
podcast answers from the hours of 4 P.M
to 407 p.m in the zip code you know of
whatever
sure but as of right now at a macro
level there is nothing that I am trying
to be the best at that I'm actually the
best at but I don't let it damage my
self-esteem to stare nakedly at my
inadequacies because my self-esteem is
built around entirely being the learner
acknowledging where I'm lacking right
lacking in the sense of there's a gap
between where I am and where I want to
be that's the lack self-defined and I'm
willing to stare nakedly at that and say
cool this person up here is better than
me I want to beat them I want to get
better than them but I also need to
acknowledge what they're better than me
at now can I just get better than them
at that thing do I need to find a
separate thing for me to get good at
right so if I were trying to play
basketball I'm not going to try to beat
LeBron James in a one-on-one he has
physical attributes that I think it
would be next to impossible for me to
counter directly but but there are other
things that I might be able to get good
at I might be able to read the court
better I might be better at passing who
knows but you go and identify given the
50 of me that's hardwired that I can't
change and the 50 of me that is
malleable how do I bring the reality of
those two things together in a way that
allows me to perform at the level that I
want so you've identified what it is
you're underperforming at and now you're
going to go into deliberate practice so
there's a book by Anders Erickson called
peak in that book he breaks down the
process of deliberate practice of how
you take the things that you're not good
at not the things you already are good
at which is what most people will tell
you lean into your strengths that's some
you yes know what your
strengths are yes leverage them whenever
you're in a performance situation and
you have to outperform but when we're
talking about practice
we don't want to lean into the things
that we already do well we want to
systematically
break out the things that we're not good
at and find a way to do a a practice
cycle a repetition cycle that allows us
to actually get better this is not blind
repetition this is strategic repetition
designed to give a desired outcome
whether it's being able to reach music
faster you're going to have to be able
to measure this stuff so figuring out
what it is finding a way to measure it
finding a way to break down the practice
elements into steps so that you get
better at one small thing which stacks
on another small thing which stacks on
another small thing until you're
actually bringing all of these small
things that you have practiced
religiously diligently deliberately to
get better and now when you go back to
perform again you're able to perform at
a higher level so not accepting a
plateau is a big part of it not thinking
well when I've hit this Plateau that
just is what it is and I've reached the
limits I can pretty much assure you
nobody is ever going to reach the limits
of their capabilities before they die
there just isn't enough time so
breaking it down into those smaller
pieces that stack practicing the things
you're bad at grouping it back together
and then going out to perform and not
letting yourself get overwhelmed by the
uncertainty that is the answer rule
number seven Define your rules the thing
that I love is that you're using the
word build because that's exactly what
we're going to be doing here you're
going to construct what you want your
life to be you're going to break it up
into different hours and segments so you
know when it's go time and then you're
going to build rules into your life that
mandate that you show up during those
times so I have a whole host of rules in
my life they can be small simple rules
like I get out of bed in 10 minutes or
less they can be more profound and
impactful goals or excuse me rules and I
have a rule in my life where Monday
through Friday if I'm awake I'm either
working or working out so if I were
doing something like you in this
situation I would say okay these two day
two hours or five hours however much
time it is that you want to allocate to
the business you're gonna say I am
working on the business business during
these times I'm going to tell myself I'm
going to tell other people that way
there's accountability then I'm going to
score myself at the end of that session
did I show up did I start when I said I
was going to start did I go hard the
whole time and I'm just going to give
myself a rating every day depending on
where I'm going how I did that day was I
distracted did I have flow was it a
great day a bad day and by doing that
I'm going to hold myself accountable so
I can see over time that I show up when
I said I was going to show up what was
the score that I gave myself for staying
focused staying on task and getting
things done and then the third thing to
really make this stick
you've got to find a way to be excited
about what you're doing and oftentimes
when people come and they say that
they're having trouble making a new
habit stick the reality is they just
don't want it badly enough and when you
realize that that's not an indictment on
you as a person that's a simple
statement about the fact that desire is
a process so you don't there's very few
things in your life that you just sort
of automatically are excited about most
of things if you really want to kick ass
at something you've got to build a ton
of energy into getting excited about
that thing now that comes in a couple
different forms number one is your why
why are you doing this so it might be
hey my husband and I were really excited
about this this is going to be our path
to freedom and building something with
him like this means everything to me and
I couldn't be more excited more honored
to be working side by side with my
husband to build something to show each
other what we're capable of to take care
of each other to you know give ourselves
what we need to build a family whatever
you're going to make that why you're
gonna say it you're going to say it with
enthusiasm it's what I call embodying
what you want to feel so if you want to
be excited when you're telling other
people when you're even talking to
yourself when you're talking to your
husband you're actually going to let
yourself get hyped up there's a
mechanism in the brain that says whoa
hey we're all hyped up about this it
must actually be worth being hyped up
about and it becomes a self-reinforcing
loop so we've got our why and then we
want to make sure that we're putting the
identity into it that we want to get out
so if we want to be the kind of person
that shows up and works hard then we say
I'm the type of person that shows up and
works hard and you're going to lean into
that and the why that you have with your
husband you guys are building something
you're excited about it you're telling
other people you're embodying it and now
you've got the identity statement if I'm
the type of person that does this I see
this through and you repeat that
cocktail over and over over and over and
following it up with that score and all
of a sudden over time and it will take
time because it is a process but over
time you're going to stick to it because
it means something to you and your
husband you've got the rule about
showing up you're rating yourself on how
you did that day you're feeling good on
the days you killed it and you're
reminding yourself to dig a Little
Deeper on the days where you don't and I
promise if you just work that process
over and over and over two weeks a month
into this it's just going to be second
nature you're going to be showing up
you're going to be excited you're going
to see it through rule number eight lead
by example one of the things I think
people don't understand about being a
CEO is that ultimately being a CEO
running a company is almost I mean it's
70 percent people I mean the strategy is
definitely important but man momentum
isn't about moving fast or I should say
it isn't just about moving fast it's
about getting a group of people pointed
in the same direction and moving fast
and so understanding how to Galvanize a
team and get them pointed in the same
direction is really really critical so
in this specific time number one is
leading by example always and forever if
you want to do anything when people are
involved whether it's kids whether it's
somebody you love that is
um there's a piece of advice you
definitely that desperately want them to
take and they're not taking it whether
it's your company the answer is always
first and foremost lead by example that
is critically important so you want to
be hopeful you want to be optimistic you
want to show them through your behaviors
and your actions time and time again
with an inhuman level of consistency
exactly how to fail base adversity now
you don't want to you don't
want to lie so you want to make sure
that you're doing the work to make sure
that you're keeping yourself hopeful and
optimistic now how do we stay hopeful
and optimistic we have to have certain
beliefs in place and we have to have
certain rules in place so first of all
as it comes to rules I know that I
always need to be moving forward I can't
ever be afraid to make a decision that I
would rather be running a thousand miles
an hour in the wrong direction than
standing still okay that rule has served
me very well now why is it better Tom
you're running in the wrong direction
that's way worse than standing still
not true the reason that you never want
to stand still is there's zero progress
made when you stand still when you move
you're at least learning even if you're
moving in the wrong direction failure is
the most information Rich data stream
you will ever encounter let me say that
again
failure moving in the wrong direction is
the most information Rich data stream
you will ever encounter meaning you're
going to learn a lot so now when you
turn around and you start moving in the
right direction you're making a huge
amount of progress so even though yes
you have to backtrack it's still far
better than standing still and not
learning those lessons so that is huge
so you have that rule now beliefs you
need to believe that if it doesn't
violate the laws of physics then you can
solve the problem what happens is most
people stay in this Frame of Mind where
all they can see are the problems and
right now there is an avalanche of
problems it is so easy to get mired in
the problems
but if you have a belief that as long as
it doesn't violate the laws of physics
this is possible that any obstacle can
be overcome that you just have to figure
out what it is that's going to allow you
to go over this obstacle under this
obstacle through this obstacle around
this obstacle whatever but you know that
giving up is not an option now it's like
cool hey even if I fail even if I mess
up I'm going to learn so there's some
hope there's some optimism right you can
meet your team with a truism something
that you actually believe you can use
Jocko willing's language which he says
anytime something goes wrong his only
response is good the enemy is bearing
down on us good we don't have enough
equipment good and because he meets it
with that he stays in a solution
oriented mindset now you always want to
be in a solution-oriented mindset when
all you're doing is focusing on the
problems and the most Sinister thing
about excuses is how valid they are so I
get it you have every excuse in the book
for things to fail to not be optimistic
to not be hopeful I get it and it's all
real we are going through the most most
devastating time for a business ever
and how do I respond to that good
because I know in this there is going to
be a solution and I'm going to figure it
out where a lot of people are going to
break because they're not going to be
able to get their head in the right
place so my team can see that I'm
hopeful I'm optimistic because I have
that belief because I have the rule to
be moving forward to figure this out to
not be afraid to fail and they see me
with that like almost naive optimism
always moving forward but they also see
me learning from my mistakes reorienting
and moving forward again if you can do
that you're actually going to get
results and nothing is more hopeful than
results rule number nine turn your wants
into needs turning a want into a
crushing need is one of the most useful
processes that you can master and
when you understand that we don't get
what we want but we get what we need
then you begin to understand okay this
is something I want to learn how to line
up so I want to take this thing that I
want and isn't a need it really is just
a want and I want to figure out the
process of how I increase its level of
importance in my mind so one of the most
important things to understand about the
human brain is that the the brain the
conscious mind will
work backwards to justify what it's done
so the the human brain is absolutely
fascinating and it has a mechanism so I
talk about this thing called the physics
of Being Human like what does the brain
just do in and of itself and one of the
things that the brain does in and of
itself always and forever is it will
justify what happens there's this
amazing thing a study that was done on
people that have short-term memory loss
so that they cannot form new memories
they they have brain damage that makes
it impossible for them to form new
memories so a doctor will go in they
will have a pin on their hand they will
shake hands with a person it pokes them
person jerks their hand back now
remember they cannot form new memories
so that Dr Jabs them and they're in pain
they pull their hand away the doctor
comes back five minutes later the person
does not remember meeting them at all
but they still won't shake their hand
now when you ask them oh why won't you
shake my hand they will make up and
they'll be like well I've just always
had this problem with shaking people's
hands that are wearing white lab coats
which is total five minutes ago they
were more than happy to shake that
person's hand so that is the conscious
mind needing to make sense of what's
going on in the subconscious mind
because the way that memories are stored
are very different so you have the
implicit the explicit memory so you've
got something that's happening
consciously and subconsciously so the
short-term memory is not turned into
long-term memory and so they don't
remember why they're doing this thing
but the part of the memory that's
working based around the pain and
knowing what causes pain stimulus
realizes that this person generates pain
but the subconscious speaks an emotion
it doesn't speak in language and so the
rational logical mind tries to then make
sense of what is going on so we're gonna
hijack that to work for us here in this
example where we want to get hyped up
about something but we want it to be
real so we know that the my is doing
this and yes we're totally hacking the
mind yes we're playing a bit of a game
with ourselves but it ends up having
this incredible impact so what I do is I
embody the passion that I want to feel
so like I'm doing now you can imagine if
you're sitting in a room with me I would
probably be speaking much more subdued
but because I understand that the
passion that I'm feeling is infectious
to other people that if I can embody it
then I can get other people to feel it
as well now the crazy thing is is it
works in a loop and I actually begin to
feel that the response that I'm having
is the right amplitude so even if I'm
merely consciously turning the dial of
excitement up or whatever about the goal
that we have because I know that I want
to Spring out of bed in the morning I'm
going to dial that up and say this thing
that I'm working towards it isn't a want
this is a need I've got to have this and
this is why I have to have it and I'm
going to create some logic that really
means something to me and I'll give you
an example at quest to show up every day
and to fight that hard to learn
manufacturing to spend my time repairing
equipment it was crazy and there were
times it was so frustrating and I knew
for me to do something I didn't want to
do that I was going to have to leverage
that notion so I said going into it how
do I attach to building a nutrition
company to something that I care
intrinsically about deeply about and
that thing became my mom and my sister
and so I said okay this is really
powerful because I can show up every day
and fight for my mom and my sister so
how do I associate my mom and my sister
to a nutrition company and the answer
was very simple my mom and my sister
were morbidly obese and I wanted to help
make food that they could choose based
on taste and it happened to be good for
them and if I could do that that they
would be in my life longer they would
live longer healthier lives they would
feel better so when a piece of equipment
broke down or I was dealing with
something incredibly frustrating where I
was working insane hours it was just hey
I'm doing this for my mom and my sister
and I would embody that and I would tell
people that and I would feel it I would
get amped up the way that I'm doing
right now I would literally say things
like this like a crazed man and it began
to infuse so that over time six months
12 months it was like I really felt like
this was a crusade for my mom and my
sister and that is so powerful the
ability to take something that you care
deeply about marry it to a goal that you
care about so that you have this
emotional resonance with that thing
is very very powerful so that's the
brain hack that you're going to use to
get yourself super excited and Rule
Number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is learn to take
criticism looking at and understanding
who that person is what your
relationship is with them how much they
can take what
what the nature of your relationship is
with them in terms of feedback so for
instance there's a person on our team
his name is Will voo now will came to me
one day and said he's been working with
me for a couple years and he said Tom I
want to be honest with what my goal is
here at impact Theory and I said amazing
tell me all about it and he said I want
to be co-ceo and I said all right but if
you're really gunning for that like we
can play a game and all just sort of
giggle and laugh and say
um how cute that will at the time he was
probably 19 or 20 that he said that you
know how cute that will is calling his
shot like Babe Ruth and saying that he
wants the the top job or I can take that
really seriously and now we can talk
about what would it really take to get
to that point and if you're giving me
permission which is something that I'll
do a lot with people is you tell me you
know how hard basically you want to be
pushed because I'm happy to like if you
want to know what it takes to to get to
your goal right everything is an echo of
your goal he gave me his goal and I said
cool if that's really how you want me to
treat you like I'm grooming you to be
the co-ceo it's going to be hard and we
just had a call like yesterday or the
day before where
um he brought something up he said
something that I would have let slide
and virtually anybody else and I stopped
him in the middle of that I told him why
it didn't make sense he pushed back I
started escalating it got to the point
where I was like look if you really want
to be the CEO you've got to think in a
way that is always solution oriented you
cannot be pushing off something making
it somebody else's problem or saying
that that's too big and that you're not
going to be able to overcome that and so
you just sort of move on without
thinking about it I'm like you are
literally poisoning the rest of this
team because subliminally you've told
them that this can't be done and so
going through that I would not have done
that with other people I wouldn't have
gone that hard I might have suggested
hey there's a better way to frame this
or whatever but with will because he has
specifically asked me to actually help
him develop the skill set that he will
need to be the CEO that I treat him
differently than I might treat somebody
else now everybody in the organization
we have a total transparency culture but
you have to earn your way into that so
one you're only as good as what you
write down so we have published what our
culture is so we have a culture document
it tells you exactly what a principal's
culture is it tells you what we mean by
transparency it tells you that we expect
people to own it meaning your opinion
speak up or get out and so we hold
everybody to that standard and so there
is a lot of open discussion now we can
do that because everybody who's here
knew that before they came on and
they've bought into that culture and
they see the benefits of that culture
and so by communicating what that is
laying the ground rules having you know
Rules of Engagement which I'm sure as a
military person you're intimately
familiar with once you have those Rules
of Engagement then it's like hey this is
how we agreed we were going to deal with
each other you agreed you wanted to be
pushed this way and that to me is very
important now one thing that I will
throw in there is be careful who you
hire some people just are not going to
have the
um the makeup for that I won't even say
it's good or bad I'm just saying they're
they approach the world in a very
different way they want their feedback
in a very different way they may not
want to be pushed like you want to push
them and so you have to know going in
whether somebody is going to be a
cultural fit I think it's as important
to judge a cultural fit as it is to
judge a skill set fit so if you get all
of those Rules of Engagement a good
cultural fit you've written down the
culture you've discussed it you have
buy-in and permission from the person
now you can be very open and back and
forth and then if you really want to
bring it home you're going to make sure
that you're as receptive to that kind of
feedback as you would expect them to be
so if you lead by example and you're
showing people what it means to take
criticism to be pushed to want to know
where you're weak and then to work to
get better at that when people see that
man and then you come to them and say
hey of course in a compassionate way but
never sacrificing Clarity for kindness
but you tell them hey here's you know
where I think you are lacking here's
what I think that you should do to
improve that
um people know the sincerity of it
because they've been on the other side
and told you where they think you're
weak and how they think you can improve
and if you took that on well and
actually did something about it and
actually got better and that we're all
reaping results because of that
Improvement now people are really going
to be open to it because you've set the
tone and that is certainly how I do it
healthy relationships are a critical
part of The Human Experience
if you truly want to live a joyful life
you need to make sure that you have
close loving relationships if you don't
currently have close loving
relationships
do not pass go do not collect two
hundred dollars immediately address that
in your life if you need to start
somewhere and you have no idea where to
start man go to a soup kitchen do
whatever but get out with other people
start connecting to people do something
some kind of way join join a Facebook
group join a club virtual or in person
whatever weird interest you have I
promise there are other people out there
that have that same interest this was so
10 years ago maybe more 15 years ago
when I learned about furries which I
still am surprised is the thing but it
is a thing and the fact that even
pre-internet there were entire groups of
people that would meet up and this is
our thing I thought okay if there's
people that are into that no shade man
if that's your thing that's your thing
but if there is a conventions worth of
people that are into that
then there is a group of people for
every interest no matter how
Niche so find your people connect
that is hugely important and then don't
look for other people to carry you but
having people in your life that support
you that and this is the easiest way to
explain this from my wife I say I'm not
looking for sympathy okay I don't want
you to feel bad for me
empathy that would be amazing I want you
to understand what I'm going through
now here's how it plays out
I said to her in the beginning if ever
I'm knocked to my knees I don't want you
to get on your knees with me put an arm
around me cry with me and tell me
everything is going to be okay it's not
what I'm looking for and even worse I
don't want to do all that and then tell
me yeah all of this sucks and it's in
life you know Life's a sandwich and
every day is another bite
people used to say that all the time
when I was a kid that was like the
Tacoma motto drove me crazy
what I want
my beloved wife
when I'm knocked to my knees which will
happen
I'm going to extend a hand
I want you to show that you understand
what I'm going through but I want you to
pull me back up
help brush me off and remind me of what
I'm capable of
so that I can
soothe myself
refocus remember that I'm the learner
and get me pointed back in the right
direction
that to me is the difference between
empathy and sympathy
Don't Cry For Me
help me get back in the fight
so surround yourself with people that
are like that don't look for them to
carry you
having people that remind you of what
you're capable of having people remind
you of what you're capable of becoming
that's rad that's dope surround me with
people like that and I'm about it but I
don't just want somebody to cry with me
it's not going to take me where I want
to go to make progress and to fail
forward to really figure out when you
make this catastrophic error
you have to conceptualize it in the
right way so when you're trying
something recognize that as a hypothesis
so number one is to recognize I have a
goal my goal is over there I'm here
there's a gap between my goal and I I
need to know what that Gap is I need to
understand it I need to know what the
impediment is I need to recognize why if
I just keep doing the thing that I'm
doing now why am I not going to get
where I'm going okay so first you have
to identify that now once you identify
that then it becomes a question of what
is your best guess which we will call it
which is called a hypothesis so you make
that hypothesis which again is just your
best guess as to what you would need to
do it's very important this isn't
thinking we're not going to live in the
abstract that when we finish this it's
going to tell us to do something so what
would I need to do
in order to overcome the obstacle that
stands between me and my goal if your
major goal is like way down the road
you're going to have to break it down
into smaller goals and so this goal with
my next 15 minutes is how I tell people
to think of it when you understand your
goal clearly enough and you understand
the impediments clearly enough you know
exactly what you should be doing with
the next 15 minutes okay that's the
level of clarity that you need so okay
cool
I've identified this
what the thing is that I believe I need
to do it's a guess
don't wait for lightning to strike don't
wait for anything to be self-evident
you have a best guess as to what you
should do with the next 50 minutes and
then your 15-minute stack up to your
best guess you know over uh a week or a
month or a quarter you know whatever
however big that project is
then you're going to do that thing
so I have a hypothesis on what would be
the most efficient way most effective
way for me to overcome this obstacle and
then I'm going to do that thing and that
thing is either going to work or it's
not and if it works amazing did it work
as well as it could have if not and I
have to do this it's something I have to
do again then refine and do it again if
it did then what's my next obstacle and
I'm going to do that one now eventually
you're going to do something and it
doesn't work it either you stood still
or you made so little progress as to be
Unworthy of Celebration or maybe you
even move backwards maybe this is that
moment where you totally embarrass
yourself maybe this is something that
happened down public and now you look
like a total ass and in that moment you
need to go okay
why did this not work okay so this is
where we analyze the data now the key to
analyzing the data is before you run
this experiment you need to say what
success looks like so all right if I
think here's my best guess as to what I
need to do to overcome this problem
and here is what success will look like
so let me give you an example
we had a hypothesis I still can't
believe that this is true but it is we
had a hypothesis here on our YouTube
channel that if we put
guests uh if we took a photo of them or
pulled a screenshot from the episode
where they're doing something with their
hands that the click rate will go up and
that the click rate will positively
impact our monetized views okay so
that's our hypothesis we test it
I still can't believe this is true but
it works and it doesn't just work most
of the time it works almost all of the
time now nothing is you never have one
blanket statement where it truly works
for everything but I'm talking north of
95 so hey we had this hypothesis it
worked we did it now the number of times
where we had a hypothesis hey uh
should put make the text white with a
drop shadow we tried it and that didn't
work and it's like wow I can't believe
that didn't work it looks so much better
than black text
but it keeps losing over and over and
over so in that moment it's like okay
well I really thought this was gonna
work but it didn't work and you try
something else now when it's something
where there's emotion involved that gets
harder for people to get clear on what
the data is and that's why you have to
have a uh a very clear understanding of
what success looks like you're setting
your expectations too high
you're triggering this sense of
inadequacy in yourself so I will tell
you that kicking yourself in the ass is
super powerful
but my rule is I never do anything that
diminishes my sense of self why because
it actually makes you less effective and
effectiveness at moving towards my goal
is the barometer by which I judge
whether something was a success or not
and if I've made a decision and it moves
me away from my goals because it's
making me feel badly about myself
because I've set a standard that's too
high I'm nitpicking myself to death now
I'm getting worse that's moving me away
from my goal and so I'm not going to do
that I don't allow that in my life I
don't allow it in my life I do not allow
myself to do things that diminish my
sense of self and move me backwards so
when I feel it happening I'm like hey
even if it's true even if I Am The
Biggest Loser That Ever Walked this
Earth reinforcing that in myself will
make me capable of less therefore I
don't do it I have a bright line in my
life that says I only do and believe
that which moves me towards my goals so
we're just going to recognize as we set
these expectations that it doesn't make
sense to do anything that diminishes
ourselves so we're not going to set
expectations that are so high that we
know that we are bound to fail or to set
high expectations I love that reach for
the farthest star in the world
but don't value yourself for whether or
not you achieve it value yourself for
the sincere Pursuit meaning you really
showed up you really tried to get to
that far star to achieve some insane
goal it was not rhetoric you really
showed up you got in there you bled for
this thing but the whole time you're
valuing yourself you're cheering
yourself on because you're really trying
you're the man in the arena
covered in Blood Sweat and dirt
you might be getting your ass handed to
you
but you're trying and if you're trying
then you should be rewarding yourself
and if you're rewarding yourself then
you should feel better about it which
makes you more likely to get back in the
ring and fight and if that is the thing
that leads you towards your goals which
of course it is then we know that we are
going to do and believe in that thing
because now we're in the arena we're
fighting our behaviors line up with our
desire to achieve that goal so don't
worry about whether or not you actually
ever get there because let me tell you
success
cannot be guaranteed struggle can you
will struggle I cannot guarantee that
you will be successful
the juice is never going to be the
success it's never going to be the
accolades just as there is no Feast so
Grand that you will never be hungry
again
there is no accomplishment so profound
that it won't be fleeting
no matter how big no matter how much
money you make
it will never be quote unquote enough
because you're playing a game of
neurochemistry and your neurochemistry
is designed to no matter how big your
meal was last time to get you back out
hunting again it's just how it works all
desire is like that it's cyclical
it'll feel awesome for a minute for a
day for a week maybe a month
but let me tell you you're going to want
to get back out there you're going to
want to hunt you're going to want to
accomplish again so don't value yourself
for that this is how people end up
making a billion dollars only to feel as
lost and empty as ever
you have a hole inside of you that can
only be filled with progress meaning and
purpose it can't be filled with
accomplishment irony of ironies
but that's the way an evolutionarily
derived mind works
you have to be pushed to go on the
journey
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over
satiety
satisfaction contentment
or anathema
to Nature to survival so of course
you're never going to be able to sit in
that
you're going to keep going again and
again and again and again
so Embrace that drive
accomplish huge things if you can
but only value yourself for the sincere
Pursuit the reality is that those who
can delay eating the marshmallow the
longest do the best because you're right
delaying gratification is an absolute
superpower now one of the most
extraordinary experiments was done at
Stanford University it's called the
marshmallow experiment there's a whole
book written on this utterly fascinating
they followed the participants in the
study for like 25 years absolutely
incredible they bring these kids into a
room they give them a marshmallow and
they say Hey you can eat the marshmallow
now if you want but if you wait until I
come back then I'll give you two
marshmallows so it's basically double
your money it's not going to be that
long now what the kid doesn't know is
that the researcher isn't coming back
and they just want to see how long the
kid is going to wait until they eat it
they do eventually come back but they
leave them really to struggle for quite
some time and
what they found was the kids that could
come up with games where they're singing
to themselves not looking at the
marshmallow whatever the kids that were
able to delay the gratification the
longest ended up doing the best they got
the best grades they got the highest
paying jobs they had the most successful
relationships now the reason that that
works is in any one moment if you're
just operating around optimizing for
momentary mind States brain States
neurochemical states then you're always
going to be in short-term thinking
you're always going to get short-term
results if however you have this goal
that excites you and is Honorable
and you're able to push through all the
boring stuff and all of that then what
you get is a set of skills that allow
you to do things other people can't do
and as we establish in the last question
if you can do things other people can't
do that is by its very nature success
and you will be rewarded in a way that
other people will not be rewarded
because they can't do the things you do
and as long as the things you do are
valued by Society then you are always
going to do very well
but that ultimately is the key you have
to be able to delay gratification now
for me understanding that that was the
nature of things that if I can delay my
momentary wishes for something longer
term then I could get these very
different results that separated me from
other people and because I'm excited
about what I'm pursuing I use that
excitement as my trick to stay focused
when things get boring and I've said
many times that boredom kills more
entrepreneurs than failure so everyone
will tell you that fear of failures what
stops people and that is a huge deal but
honestly like I think it's the fact that
people don't want the outcome badly
enough to fight through all the boring
painful stuff that you have to go
through to get to the other side to
ultimately be successful so
make sure that you are hyped up on your
goal if you're not then you're not going
to be willing to go through all the
difficult things here is the reality
when it comes to figuring out where to
start the truthful answer is guess and
get going the reason people say just
throw them into the deep end is because
let me tell you you start trying things
real fast when you're sinking to the
bottom of the pool hey does splashing my
arms around like this word that's
kicking my legs like this work just
grabbing at the person next to me and
like trying to climb up them does that
work that's you running a bunch of
experiments which you never would have
done sitting on the bank thinking about
it you will not be able to think your
way to success that doesn't mean that
you shouldn't think it just means when
you think and then go either a lot of
time has passed so I would say if you've
thought for more than 72 hours about it
thinking is no longer going to help that
window though very beneficial sleep on
it a couple nights really think through
it do some research but now Post 72
hours it's time to take action now that
doesn't mean that we're not gonna think
about it anymore we're not going to
research we are a whole lot but that
research magnifies paired with action so
now reading an article listening to a
podcast is paired with flailing around
like an idiot in the deep end going oh
my God now I see what they were trying
to explain in that book that article
that video whatever but you're never
going to be able to make those
connections if you're not actually in it
so you're not going to think your way to
success you are definitely going to get
in there and do your way to success
that's a critical thing there's no
magical First Step you're so worried
about the first step because you think
that there's some like magical
auspicious first step that's like and I
see this now with um nft artists where
it's like oh man but my Genesis piece
means everything and so they don't
create anything because they are so
worried about what their first piece is
that noise do something create get out
there try
longevity
longevity that's the game
and if you would allow me an aside
there was a class I forget where this is
so interesting bear with me
when our teacher said
you have two options before you
your final grade can either be based on
a single piece and that's all you have
to create this entire time or
I can grade you based on the pounds of
art that you output literally the pounds
the weight the number of items that you
create I think this was a sculpture
class
so you've got people that are like hey
amazing I'll take all my time I'll do
one thing it's going to be amazing and
she said without question like 95 of the
time the best grades went to the people
that did art by the pound why
because they tried and failed and tried
and failed and they weren't precious
about it and they just got in there and
they got messy and they pushed their
skills forward they got those samples
they learned they researched they tried
they had a whole bunch of stuff that was
garbage but man a few times in there
they really hit on something and they
really learned and they really pushed
themselves forward live life by the
pound now let's talk about the more
important part which is earning
credibility with yourself
this was one of the big breakthroughs in
my life was realizing that if I said I
was going to do something
and I wanted to give up on it I would
think about well if I position it this
way if I move this way if I kind of hide
this from that person and sweep this
under the rug over here then I can still
manage other people's
beliefs about who I am
and as long as other people think that
I'm cool I'm good I'm talented I'm smart
whatever then I'm good and what I
realized is a that only works fifty
percent of the time so 50 percent of the
moves that you make to try to
um
manage your persona
50 of the time it works the other fifty
percent of the time though people see
through it and then you begin to earn
the reputation of being a
artist so what I realized was okay not
only does it not work as well externally
as I think but it doesn't matter what
the outside world thinks if I don't
think positively of myself so that
became my obsession is understanding
credibility is most important when
you're talking about self-credibility
and how we earn credibility with
ourselves is by saying I'm going to do
this thing and then doing it and then
you just keep inching that out farther
and farther and farther until you get to
the point where you show up for yourself
in the most extreme and difficult of
circumstances so I'll tell you guys a
story
um at my old house I used to have this
painting of the Michael Jordan Flu Game
hanging above my fireplace and that was
so inspiring to me and I always said I
put that up there to remind myself of
what I'm capable of and how I would
react if I were put in a championship
game situation and then lo and behold
the Flash Forward probably a year later
and I actually get the flu and I have a
double episode the next day and I
remember I had a fever I was rocked I
could barely stand up it was really
miserable and I had to do all the prep
the day before for the episodes
and I was like I actually don't know if
I'm going to be able to make it through
this like it it that's how sick I was
it's one of the sickest I've ever been
in fact right now we're all gonna make a
promise to ourselves you can do it
silently we want to have everybody
shouting it out
but you're gonna make a promise to
yourself right now because if if you
follow through with what we're about to
say everything will be different if you
fail to do this you'll come back a year
from now and you're going to write the
same on the wall I promise because
this is the part that you have to break
out of make yourself a promise right now
that you will
disengage your sense of self your sense
of self-worth
from Achievement
and you're gonna marry that
to Pursuit
Once You Are Holy focused on sincere
Pursuit everything changes when you're
focused on outcome when you're saying to
yourself I want to get rich I want to
win the Academy Award ah those are my
dreams it's an end state right it
doesn't work like here's one of those
things things become trite because
they're so true so please for the love
of God don't make people repeat the most
obvious ever like money can't buy
happiness
okay money can't buy happiness it can
buy a lot of cool
it bought me a really nice house
in fact baby show the photo yeah
we actually own part of that jet company
I'm not joking how crazy is that we know
the CEO there was one time where I was
trying to get on the flight they were
giving me I can't remember why and I
called the CEO up and I was like yo you
need to talk to your gate agent
like that's money
it's bananas
money is better than you think it is
more powerful than you think but it is
not at all what you've been told money
solves money problems and that's awesome
and there's a lot of cool stuff that you
can do with money there's no joke so we
run impact Theory out of our house our
house is like 10 000 square feet
swimming pool balconies all that crazy
one of our rooms is actually called like
actually when we bought the house they
called it this it's called the great
room
and that thing is big
I'm not joking we once played um Nerf
with Nerf guns we did like a whole hide
and seek capture the flag thing in the
house
it was crazy
so money does really extraordinary
things people will chase money forever
because money actually has utility so I
am not the guy that's saying oh money
doesn't matter or money's not a thing or
money's not worth a Pursuit what I am
saying though money really can't buy
happiness the very thing you're pursuing
in your life is very simple it is
fulfillment that's it now I sum up
fulfillment very simply how do you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself
do you feel good do you feel like you're
making the most of your life are you
tapping into what the Greeks call Techni
are you working your ass off and that's
a key component is it hard are you
working your ass off
sad but true are you working your ass
off for a set of skills
this is oh you this is the angry face
this this is this is about tapping into
rage we talked about that Elizabeth not
at rage yet we'll get there
but there we go so you really have to
work hard
for a set of skills
that matter to you now the skills have
to matter that's a key part of the
equation
once the skills matter to you and they
allow you to serve not only yourself but
other people and then you actually go
and serve those people it becomes this
really potent cocktail of neurochemistry
but I want to make sure that everybody
understands the game that you're playing
is a game of neurochemistry right in the
last year at least two billionaires
committed suicide
so I mean like it's heartbreaking When
anybody commits suicide but when
billionaires start committing suicide
like if the answer is not just
self-evident beyond all imagining that
money is not going to solve the problems
that exist between your ears like
there's there's nothing more anyone can
tell you a fool never learns
a smart man learns from his mistakes a
wise man learns from the mistakes of
others on this one I'm begging you be
wise I'm not telling you not to chase
money I'm just saying it's not going to
feed you emotionally the way you think
it is so you've got to completely
Divorce Yourself from this notion of
outcome and become completely obsessed
with the idea of sincere Pursuit
now why sincere Pursuit
the reason to tie your sense of self
your self-esteem your pride your ego
your identity all of that the reason to
tie that to sincere Pursuit is it's the
only part you can control
I cannot promise you that you'll ever be
successful
you cannot promise you that you will be
but you can
promise and know if you actually did it
to show up every day and really pursue
it
you control your mindset
you control how you feel about yourself
nobody can actually get you to feel some
kind of way about yourself
you allow that in right that's like
the cheesiest self-help you're ever
gonna hear but it got cheesy because
it's so true so people repeated it a lot
and if you lose sight of that if you
lose sight of what you allow yourself to
think is going to control you at a
neurochemical level
and at the neurochemical level that's
going to influence then again how you
feel and how you think and then you get
into this death spiral where you're
thinking negative you believe in the
negative which makes you feel badly
about yourself and then you get stuck in
that and you can't get out and you see a
lot of that on the hopes and fears
people afraid they're never going to be
able to break free people in this room
that took the time to write it down that
they were never going to get out of that
negative Loop
and that negative Loop is really real
but here's the thing the negative Loop
is based in biology
and once you begin to understand what
the biology is exactly then you can
begin to take control of your life and
step one in the biological train is to
break the tie that you have between
outcome
and worth
once you begin to break that down then
you can step to naked and raw and say
all right this is just practice
and once you're in that mode of
practicing you're in skill acquisition
mode
and the name of the game is skill
acquisition like it really is sort of
that dull and boring it's just about
getting so good at something that you
can't be denied
and that's one of those things like I'm
gonna say that phrase so much that I
worry that's going to become trite but
that is one of the most
awe-inspiring Notions on the planet
the thought that you could become so
good at something
that you leave people in awe
and when you can leave people in awe you
can do just about anything you want with
your life what steps can I take to bring
my focus to the one thing I'm working on
while blocking out all else
all right so the real key is you've got
to learn to compartmentalize so what I
do to begin my compartmentalization is I
create a list of all the important
things that I should be working on I put
that list in order this is very
important getting good at prioritizing
is an art form it is critically
important that you get good at that art
form and as you begin to break things
down and put them in order now you can
tell yourself hey this is what I should
be working on right now so rather than
trying to digest all the different
things that have to be done it's I'm
focused on this one thing right now and
my only job right now is to focus on
that thing and so by not letting your
mind wander and this meditation is very
good at bringing your focus back to the
breath which teaches you to bring your
focus back to whatever so I've got a lot
of things many things competing for my
attention but I know what my important
things are I'm working on the number one
thing right now let's say and so up this
is my entire world and if I find myself
wandering I bring myself back now part
of the reason that I can invest so
heavily in that is because I have the
belief that that's the most effective
way to work so since behaviors follow
beliefs you want to make sure that you
put that belief in place which is true
by the way that you can do everything
that you want to do just not all of it
at once so everything has to be done
sequentially you can't do everything at
the same time and this is why you have
to prioritize things out so if we know
that multitasking is actually a myth and
that you can put people in brain
scanners and what you're seeing people
who seem like they can multitask what
they're doing is called rapid switching
so they don't have what I have which is
high switching costs when I get in a
flow man I can go and go and go but if I
try to bounce back and forth between
things then I pay this high price and
inefficiency between the switching costs
of moving from switching from that task
to this task so I focus I stay on one
thing I have them in order I know what
I'm working on I remind myself that I
only have one job in that moment that is
to work on that thing I know that that's
the most efficient way to work and I
know that I'm good at prioritizing
things so it becomes very easy boom boom
boom and then you just hold yourself
accountable to actually doing that
practice makes perfect you might have a
difficult time in the beginning start
meditating if you need to to train
yourself to come back to the breath over
and over and over and then you can just
apply that to whatever you're working on
come back to the project discipline now
we're not doing discipline because our
parents tell us to we're doing
discipline as a test to see if it work
to get us towards our goal now if you
have historically struggled with putting
discipline in place in your life right
now you're going to say but Tom I can't
stick to discipline so why would this
work this time that's when we realize
one fundamental truth
this is a desire problem
masquerading as a discipline problem
once you want your goal
the way that a drowning man wants his
next breath you will find discipline
very easy to stick to and so learning to
build your desire for the goal that you
have set for yourself that becomes the
incredibly important part and the way to
dial that desire up is to do a loop and
it goes like this you're going to tell
yourself that you're very excited about
this goal
you're going to tell other people that
you're very excited about this goal and
then you're going to embody
the feeling the amplitude that you want
to feel when you think about that goal
now there's a mechanism in the human
mind where it will justify the way that
you act no matter what I won't waste
time explaining some of the studies but
they are utterly fascinating about how
even people with damaged areas of the
brain will end up making up random ass
stories because the brain aborts a a
lack of reason so the the brain will
always and forever make up some story
about why you're doing what you're doing
and so if you're responding hugely to
something oh my God I'm so excited about
doing this thing like I'm really amped
up about it and you're saying that to
yourself and you're saying it to other
people and you're saying it just like
that
then the brain goes there must really be
something here we've got this elevated
level of emotion amazing let's leverage
that and the brain doesn't say let's
leverage that but the brain will say
okay we've got this elevated level
you're going to leverage the fact that
the brain says that to repeat it to
reinforce and over time you actually
just will feel that heightened level of
emotion it's the way the brain works
what you repeat you become neurons that
fire together wire together things that
you do frequently including embodying
that amplitude of emotion right Lisa
Feldman Barrett's book how emotions are
made talks about how it starts with the
body and then the brain applies meaning
to it so if you're getting amped up
you're excited the body is saying to the
brain yo like we're amped we're excited
we're doing these things and the Brain
goes oh amazing it must be because this
really matters and once you get the
brain saying hey we're this excited
because it matters you're firing those
neurons together
the excitement around this thing so the
excitement and the pursuit of that thing
begin to mesh and now we just over time
have a an actual desire to pull this off
once we have the actual desire to pull
this off then all of a sudden putting
that discipline in place becomes very
easy
and that's the name of the game
you want to make it such that you want
it badly enough that the discipline
becomes easy to stick to because it's
going to move you towards that thing
that you really want
but you've got to learn
you've got to learn to want that thing
now
I'll give my typical disclaimer
this trick works incredibly well now it
only works on things you actually have a
legitimate interest in you couldn't
um get yourself excited about something
that you truly just find stupid but
something where you actually do get a
natural response you actually are
naturally into that thing all we're
doing is dialing it up right so if it's
already a dial tone there's nothing you
can do to change the amplitude but if
the amplitude is already there and you
get this reaction we can really
exaggerate that reaction and build that
desire to get where we're going now
since that is the case you need to be
very careful what you apply this to
because you can end up really wanting
some stupid I know from experience
I dialed the dial on my desire for money
I cranked that to a 20. and then spent
eight and a half years pursuing money
only to come out completely miserable so
don't waste your time dialing that up on
something that isn't exciting and
honorable meaning again honorable it
elevates you and other people not just
you
all right
be careful what you decide to want but
know that it's very powerful I will tell
you that my to-do list is always in
order of importance and I think that
there is an optimal order to do things
in so important things 100 using the
lead Domino strategy so what's the
biggest bang for my buck what could I
spend the next 15 minutes on that would
have the biggest impact in leading me
towards my goals okay that's how I
always think about my official to-do
list now when I think about a morning
routine and what order I'm gonna do
things in then it has to do with what's
going on in my life at that point what's
the most important thing to me in that
moment and then ordering things
accordingly so there have been times in
my life where the first thing I do is
meditate
there have been times in my life where
the first thing I do is go to the gym
and so those are really the big two
things that I um oscillate between but
there are also times where I will
immediately go to work so any one of
those three things may be the first
thing that I'm doing in my morning
routine depending on what's going on in
my life so how do I decide between those
so when I'm really focused on getting my
physique in order I'm focused on
um the gym as being the the thing that I
want to make sure that no matter what
else happens during the day I get that
done then I do that first and that
really is what slot number one is for in
any morning routine is what is the most
important thing that you know no matter
what else Falls by the wayside during
this day if it gets crazy things will
crop up that I know that I'm going to
get that thing and so right now I'm
going to the gym first there was a long
stretch of time there where I wasn't as
focused on the gym and so it was like
well I'll work work out later let me do
a little bit of work for us and then
I'll go to the gym and I found what was
happening was instead of working out
five days a week or six days a week I
was working three days a week or
sometimes two days a week because so
much would pop up during the day that I
wasn't getting to it now that made sense
and I didn't change for a long time
because there was so many key
initiatives at impact theory that I was
trying to get to that that was truly
more important to me but then I had a
threshold event where I was like nah now
I really want to get back in and really
really focus on the gym and
ironically it was because my lower back
started to hurt from under utilization
just a quick shout out to anybody
suffering from lower back pain can
basically tell you what it is poor diet
high inflammation and not dead lifting
enough now that doesn't mean High weight
deadlifts in fact I used to do that now
I just do low rate low weight High rep
but I find that my back hurts when I
don't work it out so again everything's
individual try it out for yourself but
that's important so that's how I judge
what to do first my typical modus
operandi would be that lifting is the
first thing I do then I would meditate
and the meditation I use what I call
thinkitation to get into then the work
so working out meditating work is
typically my path
again mileage may vary try your own but
if you're not sure what to do you can
try that one
pretty damn effective for waking up the
brain
then practicing lowering your heart rate
your breathing rate by going straight
into the meditation and then when your
brain has all that Clarity that comes
from working out then you can leverage
that as you meditate to get the ideas
you're going to need to actually be
effective at work that's why I do it
you're never going to get rid of the
fear of following your passion let's
start with that
as you said there is no such thing as
arriving in life and this is one of the
main ideas that I want people to really
grapple with as you think about how to
live your life well is that there is no
success big enough that you can stand in
that success and that it will last
forever really this is a game of
neurochemistry this is how you feel this
is what stresses you out this is what do
you love this is an Ever Changing roller
coaster of
emotions and so understanding that you
could fail at a job that you hate I
think this was Jim Carrey's uh advice to
his father that you could fail at a job
that you hate so you might as well at
least try the one that you're going to
love now that doesn't mean that we just
uh throw caution to the wind and we're
going to get more into that with some of
the subsequent questions but recognizing
that
you will never
reach a destination the only destination
in life is death and that is not a
worthy aim you shouldn't be thinking
about that or focusing on that or
thinking uh in terms of you know I just
need to get to 95 or 150 or whatever age
you're aiming at this really is a
question about how you want to feel
every day and once you understand that
that there are things that make you feel
alive those things you're passionate
about those things that give you more
energy than they take and then there are
things that take more energy than they
give and so you want to be very careful
to structure your life in a way that
you're doing something that gives you
more energy than it takes okay so we
know that we're never going to arrive
because we know that we're never going
to arrive we understand that this is
really just a game of emotional
management because we know that this is
a game of emotional management then what
we're asking is what is this thing that
gives us passion is it giving us the
neurochemistry that we want or is the
thing that we're passionate about so
high risk that even though it would be
fun in the abstract once I really commit
to that and make it my job it stops
having that same sense of giving me
energy and that's the tension this is
where people end up not being able to
make a decision because they have not
yet figured out how to optimize their
life in such a way that they can pursue
that thing that they're passionate about
without
that sense of joy and excitement and
that incredible thrill of getting better
at something that you love doing and
that even when it's hard it's giving you
that energy
because people can get lost in that they
get in there they think this is going to
be amazing that passion turns into a job
and then they lose the enthusiasm or
there's so much stress and pressure
around having to be successful at that
passion because you no longer have the
safety net of a job or whatever the case
may be
um they don't recognize that just
pursuing something that's your passion
on paper isn't necessarily going to
solve that problem that the problem
fundamentally is that life is an
ever-changing roller coaster of emotion
and the name of the game is to
manage those emotions well okay so how
do we set it up if we have a passion and
we want to follow that how do we do it
well
so we know that we're never going to get
rid of the fear until we have
predictability and
um
stability in terms of the financial
things that we need and I would say we
want to take care of that we want to
make sure that we have as much Safety
and Security on the financial side as we
can to give us the room to pursue the
things we're passionate about now the
fastest way to do that is to cut your
expenses to the quick if you don't have
an expensive lifestyle this becomes a
whole lot easier and one of the mistakes
that people make is they're living a
lifestyle that's beyond their means and
so they have to keep making this massive
monthly nut and so it becomes very
stressful to pursue that thing that they
love okay so we're either going to
recognize that we have to reduce our
expenses so that we don't have to worry
so much about money or if we already
have a job that pays well we have to
pursue our passion in nights and
weekends fashion such that we can build
that Financial stability so that we can
then progress okay so getting that
stability there I think is really
important the people that have the
strongest home life take the biggest
risks and oftentimes pursuing that
passion is going to be a so instead of
trying to eliminate the fear we're going
to structure our life in such a way that
the things that trigger the fear aren't
as high risk okay that's a big part of
this then we want to make sure that
we're structuring our passion in such a
way that it doesn't end up robbing us of
the joy so we want to experiment with
what our passion looks like as a
financial Endeavor and I think that's a
very important experiment to run again
nights and weekends without making any
major life choices is going to be very
important now if we're in a situation
where the odds are stacked against you
this is where the first two things we
just walk through become incredibly
important you want to make sure that
you've got your finances taken care of
so that if this fails that it doesn't
drag you down that will make it not fun
and again there's no accomplishment so
great that you can stand in that forever
so even if you were to be successful you
still have to deal with the emotional
management
so do not put yourself in this hyper
stressful situation where it's you're
always living for the future because the
Success is Not Guaranteed but the
struggle is so the key is to struggle
well that's the answer get after it here
is how to conceptualize failure and the
disappointment that goes along with it
once you understand that what the human
animal is designed to do is learn then
you have to ask yourself if what has
made the human animal the most Apex of
apex predators the world has ever seen
the most capable of completely changing
its environment
what is it that allows them to learn
fast and the answer is failure now the
reason that failure is truly useful and
I'm not just saying that to make you or
myself feel better in fact I wish that
it wasn't the way to learn the fastest
but the reality is the reason that it
works so well is that when you fail you
trigger areas of the brain that are
focused on
memory and focus so you've got the
memory side so you're going to remember
this you've got the pain this does not
feel good I do not want to go through
this again so you've got that which
heightens your emotions which makes you
more likely to remember this thing
moving forward and then it also Narrows
your attention so you're really looking
at why did this go wrong and when you
have this sense of I never want to
repeat this and you're looking very
closely at why did this go wrong now all
of a sudden
failures because of what it does to your
brain and quite frankly because you're
in the mix you're trying things and we
learn better from doing than from
reading about it or hearing about it
so failures suddenly become the most
information Rich data stream on planet
Earth heightens your likelihood of
remembering and it focuses you in on
exactly what's the problem so now even
though failing sucks part of what makes
it valuable is that it sucks in fact it
may suck in order to make it valuable
let that sink in that nature went huh
when this happens in order for this to
be useful for this animal for this
evolutionary creature I need to make
sure
that it becomes advantageous so that as
they make mistakes assuming that they
don't get eaten by a lion I want to make
sure that they don't put themselves in
that position again and so we have to
learn from some method and the method
that gets us moving taking action trying
things feeling the pain focusing that's
going to be the thing that we're going
to get the most takeaways from so now as
you reframe what failure is failure is
not proof that you're a loser
failure is the process by which you
become better okay failure is not the
process that reveals that you're a loser
failure is a process by which you become
better that is the name of failure so
now when you fail why would you beat
yourself up over it it's the nature of
progress itself there is no way to get
better without failing it's the fastest
way it is the most effective way it is
necessary you have to do it and by the
way for you to have failed at something
you showed the courage to try it so
instead of wasting time beating yourself
up over the fact that something went
wrong we're going to say
that's the nature of progress we have to
try something it's not going to work as
well as we wanted to or I may fall flat
on my face I may outright embarrass
myself and if I let that break me I will
fail to learn the lesson
but if I do what nature is compelling me
to do
and I focus
on what went wrong why did this happen
because I never want to go through this
again
you stack enough of those what went
wrong I never want to go through this
again enough of those together
and you actually get good and
translating potential into skill set is
the name of the game and you will never
do that more efficiently than you will
through failure and mistakes so allowing
yourself to wallow in disappointment
doesn't make any sense
it's the learning process this is what
you have to do in order to get good so
there's no reason to spend a lot of time
being disappointed you brush yourself
off you pick yourself up you dust
yourself off and you get going
that's it that is the physics of
progress if grit is as important as we
say it is
sustained interest over time that's
really what grit is
and a lot of people talk about in fact
the title of my speech is supposed to be
about how you develop a passion which we
will talk about in a little bit but this
is going to be one of those things when
you have passion one of the things that
comes out of that is you've got the
ability to sustain your interest over
time do the hard things
do the hard things I can't emphasize
that one enough
put yourself in uncomfortable situations
just to find the mental tactics that
you're going to need to deal with the
hard things it's getting those tactics
who knows the Stanford marshmallow test
all right for those of you that don't
this is one of the most breathtaking
examples of The Human Condition in the
Stanford marshmallow test they bring in
I don't know they're five or six years
old they bring them in and the person in
the white lab coat says here's a
marshmallow I'm gonna go out of the room
for a minute I'll be back in just a few
minutes if you wait till I come back
I'll give you a second marshmallow so
essentially double your money
not bad
now what the kid doesn't know is the
researcher is never coming back and all
they want to know is how long will you
wait before you eat the marshmallow some
kids have literally gobbled it up before
they even get to the door
other kids are like singing to
themselves putting their head down
getting up dancing around the room some
of them bite like the underside and try
to put it back so you can't see
and here's what's scary
they followed those kids for 25 years
and based solely on the length of time
they were able to wait before they ate
the marshmallow predicted their level of
success in school
predicted their level of success in the
job market the people who waited the
longest got into the best schools got
the best grades went on to have the
highest paying jobs
just your ability to delay gratification
your ability to find tactics that work
to get your mind off something
there's no greater control than control
over oneself
anybody here ever done a three-day water
only fast not intermittent fasting
three days
do it you will learn something about
yourself and it will be profound and
what you're going to learn is that your
body is manipulative
and I did a three-day fast just a couple
weeks ago
and I had the flu right before so there
were cough drops laying around
and every time I walk by those cough
drops
my brain was like eat one
and I was like like
you know I'm fasting
and I literally couldn't believe like
how consistently every time I walk by
those damn cough drops that my body like
gave me this really intense impulse
and that's when I realized like the
notion that there are multiple voices in
your head by the way is very very real
and I will give you one quick example
who knows what the corpus callosum is
all right the corpus callosum is the
thick bit of tissue that connects the
left and right hemisphere of your brain
If you sever that you will get people
that have literal multiple personalities
one in the right one on the left some of
the most intriguing stuff is one of them
will be devoutly religious and the other
will be devoutly atheist in the same
brain and you can talk to them
differently
absolutely crazy
but the multiple voices notion is real
there are multiple
factions if you will pieces that your
brain is broken up into and by the way
you have the equivalent of a cat's brain
in neurons just in your digestive tract
so the whole notion of gut instinct
think of all the cool cats can do
and you've got that
in your digestive tract neurons
it's literally the same material that
your brain is made out of is in your
digestive tract it's utterly fascinating
so we have all these competing things
that we want
but inside if you think of that
OverWatch that one person that's you
that's meant to say I have goals and I'm
going to act in accordance with my goals
I'm never going to sell out what I want
most for what I want right now I wanted
a cough drop right now but I wanted to
get on the other side of the three-day
fast and say I did it and I wanted that
more
and in learning what your tools and
tactics are so for me I welcome hunger
like an old friend and I literally
people must think I'm schizophrenic
because you'll walk into the room and
I'll literally be like pinching and
poking at my fat going hunger thank you
I'm so glad you made it back it is so
good to see you I'm glad you're here I
know that you're oxidizing my fat I'm
very grateful for that so thank you and
in doing that I reframe it not as
something that is unwanted or painful
but it's something that is doing exactly
what I want it to do
and learning those mental tactics that's
the game learning those mental tactics
that's the game that's how you're going
to get good at whatever it is you want
to do if you want to start a business
learning how to deal with your employees
is absolutely critical but let me tell
you right now if you lash out
emotionally your employees will lose
respect for you
but it's just like the cough drop moment
now if somebody had seen me walk by the
cough drop they wouldn't know that I had
it literally had to stop myself from
lunging at a cough drop
they didn't know that because I have
control of myself
I've practiced things like that I do
three day fast I do what I call Bright
lines
so I have a bright line
during the week I don't eat my second
meal before 11 30. under any
circumstance
my wife one time brought my food 30
minutes early I Was preparing for an
episode it was so sweet of her
but I don't eat before 11 30 under any
circumstance so the food literally sat
on my lap smelling so good and I was so
hungry and I said hunger thank you so
much for showing up because you're
giving me the opportunity to prove to
myself what a badass I am
because I'm gonna smell how delicious
you are knowing my stomach is grumbling
and tying itself in knots because I want
to eat so badly and I'm not going to
and in those moments you earn
credibility with yourself
I hate working out
absolutely despise it it's why I do it
first thing in the morning
and the reason I hate it the weights are
heavy
and your muscles start burning when you
get into the supposed good reps so that
just seems backwards so it is not in any
way shape or form fun for me
but I earned credibility with myself
because it is something that I don't
like
I earn credibility with myself showing
up every day and it also reminds me how
much I can transform my body it's very
easy for me to show you my before and
after picture I used to be 60 pounds
heavier it's very easy for me to show
you when I was heavy and then show you
six pack abs you get it
but what you don't see is the body's
just a reflection of the Mind
what really happened
was I changed my mind and I had garnered
skills I had garnered tactics the things
that allowed me to not eat the coffee
drop were the things that allowed me to
not eat the things that I wanted to not
have a bowl of ice cream to not indulge
in things that are wonderfully delicious
but instead ask myself what are my goals
and then back in with my behaviors how
do you know when it's time to refuel and
choose self-care instead of continuing
to grind
physiological self-awareness is critical
I hear a lot of talk about people
developing psychological self-awareness
so understanding
um
what you're good at what you want to do
all of those things incredibly useful
but understanding how to read your body
may be even more important than that so
Lisa Feldman Barrett's book how emotions
are made detail the way that emotions
are far more of a bottom-up phenomenon
meaning they come from your body it
isn't you thinking about something and
then creating the emotion down that does
happen and of course you can spiral
yourself out of control simply by
thinking but usually what begins this
thinking process is a sense of unease
right anxiety is a bodily feeling
oftentimes disconnected from what you're
thinking so figuring out oh why do I
have the sense being able to process it
consciously we can pull it up into our
conscious mind and think through it with
words and logic but oftentimes it's
starting with that like oh man I don't
feel good about this and I don't know
why so this is the fascinating thing
about drugs is drugs can either
eliminate or change the bodily sensation
which then changes the story that you're
telling yourself about the sensation now
this isn't an advertisement for drugs
it's to get you to understand that it
can be risky to sever the sense of body
from what you're telling yourself about
it so you want your body to give you
this description of what is going on but
then as you take conscious control of
that to develop that self-awareness
around physiologically what's happening
you need to understand why you're
feeling the way that you feel and so
developing that to get a sense of
whether
this is a time to keep pushing through
or whether this is like one of those
moments where you actually really do
need to step back it's the difference
between sore muscles from you know a
nice hard workout and a torn muscle or
damage joint from an injury and the same
thing is true when you're thinking about
how hard to work how hard to push
yourself you need to figure out this
fatigue that I'm feeling this unease
this anxiety this stress is this a
natural part of pushing through the
difficulties of this project or is
something else going on this is now
really starting to cave in on me and
what I need to do now is take a step
back
meditate
Journal
hug my significant other pet my dog
cuddle my kids whatever the case may be
go for a run
but doing something that
slows you down
lets you take a deep breath
and the only way to figure that out is
to be able to interpret
the feelings that your body's giving you
into conscious thought okay and getting
good at that Loop is very very important
and it takes practice it takes
understanding what the body is
communicating why it's communicating it
what impacts it like what you eat and
drink has a huge impact on what your gut
is telling you and then your brain tries
to make sense of it and it doesn't
always go oh I'm feeling anxious because
in my case I was drinking a zero calorie
monster which much to my dismay because
I absolutely love them
make me feel anxious and so
getting an understanding of that
seeing that pattern was actually quite
transformational because I stopped
drinking them and my anxiety levels
plummeted by like 70 it's pretty crazy
didn't take me to zero but it made it a
phenomenon that was easily manageable
through meditation
so this is where you have to develop
that awareness that pattern recognition
and be able to say oh I feel this way
because of XYZ thing happening at work
or with my spouse or with food that I'm
consuming so be very thoughtful about
that and that will then help you
determine whether it's we need self-care
we just need to push through this is one
of the most common frames ever worth
being good enough being right being
smart
because these are very fragile ways to
think of yourself and I understand the
Temptation because it feels really good
when you do feel worthy it feels really
good when you are right it feels really
good to actually be the best at
something
but the truth of the world just the
truth of the world it is this way
you're always going to encounter
somebody better stronger faster more
Pious more worthy more whatever
so if you live in a world of comparison
it will rob you of your joy
even people who like Michael Jordan if
you put him right now up against most
rookies the rookie is going to win
Rookie's younger faster hungrier
Michael's just lost the step he's gotten
old
so if he were trying to make his life
about his glory in that period let's say
he lives 80 years if he's living for the
glory of 20 years that's the most
heartbreaking life I can imagine
so you're going to move in and out of
these moments where you are a badass to
where you're not a badass
don't value yourself for that
value yourself for something that is
anti-fragile
being smart being right being good being
worthy they are very fragile things
because sometimes you won't be it simply
is this way
valuing yourself for being a learner on
the other hand for trying
that's anti-fragile because the more
somebody attacks you for being dumb but
you build your self-esteem around
learning
the first thing I think when someone
says I'm dumb is awesome in what way
because I view myself in these 10-year
windows
and I know
the same people that were laughing at me
when I became an entrepreneur knew
nothing about it and I was who's the kid
in the server room and I was the only
one with an office that had no windows
and there were like nine other computers
in my room and nobody knew who I was and
the only contribution I made the phone
calls was to say goodbye at the end of a
conference call I'm not kidding
Ten Years Later
I own a billion dollar business
who the is laughing now
but it only worked because I didn't mind
looking stupid it only worked because I
wasn't asking myself whether I was
worthy or whether I deserved it I just
asked myself am I leaving it all out in
the field yes or no am I learning yes or
no and if I'm not I didn't go oh that
makes me a bad person I went I need to
change my actions to get a different
result
and once you start thinking like that
and you literally value yourself for how
hard you're trying how much you're
learning how willing you are to accept
when you fall on your face so you don't
try to get out from under it or campaign
to convince people that you're better
than you really are turn on where you're
at
because once you're real about it then
you can make progress but if your energy
Cycles go to yourself you'll
never get out of it have very clear
goals it always freaks me out most
people stop at the first sort of vague
notion of what they want to do I'm going
to punch myself in the mouth if somebody
comes up to me again and says I want to
help people
that's rad that comes from a beautiful
place I could totally get it but that's
like coming to me and saying I want to
win an Olympic gold medal awesome winter
or summer
fantastic swimming or tennis
swimming excellent
backstroke freestyle like at some point
it's got to get so specific because you
have to know what skills you need to
acquire you have to work backwards from
the goal and the goal has to be hyper
specific so if boredom is the number one
killer of entrepreneurs that they're not
able to make it through the next one is
they don't have clear goals and the
worst part is they think they do
that's the part that terrifies me the
until you know exactly what your mission
is and exactly what your business model
is and what problem you solve what very
concrete problem that people are
freaking out to have solved until you do
that you don't have the necessary
ingredients to build your business all
right don't be romantic be pragmatic
look at the data the data will tell you
what to kill the data will tell you
what's working and what's not
this was the single best piece of advice
that was ever given to me and I ignored
it for three years I'm so embarrassed by
that that I always make sure any talk I
give people hear this
know more about your product service
industry whatever than anyone else
than anyone else
if you guys have ever seen my interview
show
the reason that it's doing as well as
it's doing is I know more about the
guest one guest actually said this I
know more about the guest than their
mother
I just put in more work than their
that's the truth
I go out and I research and I read
everything and I watch every video that
I can and so I know so much about that
person I know I'm going to give a
different interview than anyone has ever
given before because nobody's done that
level of research not only does it Blow
the guest away and totally endear them
to me
but it gets us to the point where we can
give an interview that has unique value
so know more about what you're doing
than anyone else in the world and grind
baby grind for two years for two years
that's what I look like every day hair
net lab coat gloves
put in the work
put in the work and this is where the
rubber meets the road this is where
you're really going to separate the
people that are entrepreneurs from the
people that are real entrepreneurs
you've got to want to grind you've got
to learn to love that you've got to
learn to love to put in the work to be
proud of yourself that you showed up and
put in the work to be proud of yourself
that you taught yourself how to suffer
to be proud of yourself that you're
developing a mindset where you believe I
can do anything I set my mind to and by
the way
once you believe
that you can do anything you set your
mind to without limitation how you spend
your time
becomes a spiritual consideration
how you spend your time becomes a
spiritual consideration because you
could be doing something if you want to
end Hunger and hunger what's stopping
you Bill Gates is actually going to end
malaria he's going to do it because he
had the tenacity to generate the
resources and because he has a mind that
allows him to work on the infrastructure
and figure out how to actually solve
that problem
do not under any circumstances make Bill
Gates or anyone else extraordinary to
let yourself off the hook
don't do it don't sell yourself short
and this is where I see people go wrong
all the time they look at somebody who's
amazing and they say Well they're just
naturally gifted
I could never do that
you couldn't do it because you believe
you can't and because you believe you
can't you don't start putting in the
work
Michael Jordan got cut from his high
school basketball team
he wasn't exactly showing all the
promise in the world my own mother when
I left for college quietly assumed I was
going to fail and didn't admit that for
years
I showed no early signs of promise
I actually have a version of this talk
where I show photos from my childhood
and people like yeah you just look
stupid
and it's true I used to dress like a
clown and I mean that almost literally
so my waist was size 36 and I wore a
size 54 pants
I wore literal Jester hats
um I had one of those big chains that
connected to my belt uh I had shoulder
length hair I did not exactly look the
part and I didn't take myself seriously
it really is a game of transformation it
really is a game of understanding that
you can become something so even though
I didn't start with the requisite skills
even though I wasn't a born entrepreneur
which is why I start this tale with that
I could acquire and did acquire the
skills that were needed to execute
it is a very long road
that leads you here
right now
most entrepreneurs in the world are
thinking about one thing
winning a championship ring
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Simon sinek
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there there's a great
story of two Lumberjacks where every
morning they start chopping wood at the
same time and every day they stop
chopping wood at the same time and every
day one of The Lumberjacks disappears
for about an hour in the middle of the
day and every day he chops more wood
than the other guy and this goes on for
months